wir kommen jetzt nämlich zu einem sehr
wichtigen geschäftsbereich sind
natürlich alle sehr wichtig aber dieser
eben auch das ist der bereich des
bundesministeriums für bildung und
forschung
da die
eine priorisierung nämlich jetzt nicht
vor wenn der herr minister dann
vielleicht noch seine gespräche auch
nach außen verlegen könnte
von da war
dass herr minister
gelang
so dann beginnen wir jetzt aber
mit dem einzelplan 30 bildung und
forschung und das wort bekommt die
bundesministerin bettina stark watzinger
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie alle wissen die herausforderungen
die vor uns liegen sind groß und
wir alle wissen der modernisierungsdruck
war auch schon vor den jüngsten
ereignissen sehr hoch in der
finanzplanung der alten bundesregierung
ging es für bildung und forschung
abwärts und das in einer zeit in der
noch nicht krieg geherrscht hat und
keine energiekrise vorlag und ich frage
sie wo war da eigentlich die union ist
dass die vorfahrt für bildung und
forschung die sie immer in den mund
nehmen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union da hätte ich mir mehr
lautstärke von ihnen gewünscht
unterkriegen ist die trendwende in lehre
und forschung haben wieder vorfahrt in
unserem land drei milliarden euro mehr
für bildung und forschung in dieser
legislaturperiode
das sind 3 milliarden euro mehr für
deutschland zukunftskompetenz
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch dass unser
haushalt in großen teilen gebunden ist
etwa durch den stetigen aufwuchs bei
packt und war bei dem pakt für forschung
und innovation
und das ist auch gut so denn die
wissenschaft braucht verlässlichkeit
und zur wahrheit gehört auch
zur wahrheit gehört auch dass der
haushalt meiner vorgängerin ungedeckte
schecks enthielt projekte und
bauvorhaben die nicht mit genug geld mit
zu wenig geld hinterlegt haben und die
jetzt handlungsräume und freiräume
einschränken wir mussten uns als
ministerium entscheiden für einen
zukunftsfesten haushalt so eine
konsequente ausrichtung an den großen
herausforderungen
der koalitionsvertrag ist dazu unsere
leitlinie und die zeitenwende der rahmen
des machbaren meine damen
wir haben
als schossen ministerium und der danke
ich allen fraktionen die sich da
einbringen schnell umgesetzt und vor
allem das aufstiegsversprechen die
erneuerung des aufstiegs versprechens
das liegt uns besonders am herzen das
bafög ist geht in die höhe und es geht
in die breite ein milliardenpaket wir
ermöglichen damit mehr chancen und mehr
freiheit mit der exzellenzinitiative
berufliche bildung zeigen wir dass
berufliche bildung und studium gleich
panik sind wir brauchen beides in
unserem land und wir leisten damit auch
einen wichtigen beitrag gegen den
fachkräftemangel eine der größten
bedrohungen für wachstum und wohlstand
das startchancen programm
mit dem der schulen in schwierigen
umfeld stärken wollen steht vor der
verhandlungsweise meine damen und herren
das alles zeigt die chancengerechtigkeit
und der bildungsaufstieg sie sind bei
uns in dieser koalition in guten händen
wir stärken die minze
wir stärken die mint fächer mit dem
aktionsplan 2.0 denn ob klimawandel
digitalisierung oder energiekrise fast
alle großen herausforderungen unserer
zeit sind an mint kompetenzen gebunden
wir brauchen sie dringend wir werden auf
den zukunftsvertrag studium und lehre
dynamisieren das ist ein kraftakt der
die verlässliche finanzierung unserer
hochschulen in diesen schwierigen zeiten
sichert
und die exzellenz strategie für
hochschulen bringen wir in diesem jahr
in dem auf den weg auch hier
verlässlichkeit und planbarkeit für die
hochschulen in der forschung setzen wir
auf innovation und transfer und das
sowohl sozial
gesellschaftlich als auch technologisch
deshalb haben wir die gründung der neuen
agentur dati angestoßen und wir sind
dabei die fesseln der sprint zu lösen
mit dem sprint sprint freiheits gesetz
wir treiben die zukunftsstrategie
forschung und innovation voran denn wir
müssen die technologieführerschaft
verteidigen oder in italien auch noch
gelingen wir brauchen einen
innovationsschub samt transfer offensive
für unser land weil nur das wachstum und
wohlstand sichert
zukunftsfelder sind wir besonders
wichtig die bundesregierung hat das
potenzial von wasserstoff als
zukunftsenergie erkannt deshalb setzen
wir hier einen klaren
forschungsschwerpunkt das bmbf ist bei
grünem wasserstoff vordenker und
wegbereiter wir wollen die wasserstoff
republik deutschland
nach berlin
in den goldenen 20er jahren ist der m
rna impfstoff gegen das corona virus das
wunder von heute die pandemie hat
gezeigt biotechnologie ist der game
changer im gesundheitsbereich und was
heute gegen korona hilft hilft morgen
auch gegen den krebs daten sind der
rohstoff der zukunft den datenschatz zu
heben das ist eine große chance auch
fortschritt wirtschaftlich
wissenschaftlich und gesellschaftlich
kurz die chance auf fortschritt für uns
alle
und lassen sie mich mit blick auf die
jungen menschen auch noch eines klar
sagen sie haben in den letzten jahren
unter der pandemie gelitten und wurde
nur allzu oft nicht gesehen das darf
nicht wieder passieren
deshalb war uns wichtig keine
entlastungs paket ohne unterstützung
auch für junge menschen in ausbildung
das haben wir umgesetzt
meine damen und herren
es ist richtig dass wir im haushalt
stadt ein - einfluss haben das ist eine
trendwende denn jeder euro für bildung
und forschung heißt mehr chancen für
jeden einzelnen mehr chancen für die
gesamte gesellschaft jeder euro für
bildung und forschung macht und
souveräner residente und freiheit nur
mit bildung und forschung können wir
zukunft meine damen und herren
nicht der redner ist für die cdu csu
fraktion der kollege thomas jetzt blick
frau präsidentin von bundesministerin
ein jahr ist die bundestagswahl jetzt
her und ich finde es bemerkenswert dass
sie den ersten teil ihrer rede darauf
verwendet haben die alte regierung in
der vergangenheit anzugreifen
ich finde ich finde dass es dann auf den
währungsstreit weil das was wir hier
hören wollen ist doch was sie jetzt
geleistet haben dem einen jahr und was
sie vorhaben in den drei weiteren jahren
und ihre bilanz das muss man so sagen
nach einem jahr ist sie nicht blank sie
haben eine bafög reform gemacht die
deutlich geringer ausgefallen ist als
unsere letzte reform 2009/10 und das
war's ihre projekte von denen sie hier
reden die stehen doch alle in der
werkstatt und kommen nicht weiter die da
zieht die transferagentur wie oft haben
wir hier geredet ist nicht da gibt auch
kein referentenentwurf erklärte wurden
einkassiert
das print gesetz sei nicht da ich höre
street schleifen zwischen arbeitsebenen
bei ihnen und dem bmf über monate und
monaten monate ist nicht da wissenschaft
zeit vertrags gesetz handlungsbedarf
keine idee keine eckpunkte sie haben gar
nichts gesagt wo sie da eigentlich
hinwollen wenn wir aus dem silo dieses
einzel plans gucken das zimmer im
wirtschaftsministerium gestoppt bei gf
gibt's probleme sie haben gerade gesagt
sie wollen biotech machen wir haben hier
im sommer einen antrag gemacht wir haben
eine milliarde von vor gefordert wo das
geld auch da ist hat sie abgelehnt ein
pc ein biotech haben sie abgelehnt ja
noch nicht aber sie haben erklärt sie
wenn es ablehnen der digital packt 1 sie
haben hier erklärt bis zum sommer weiter
beschleunigt wenn ich raus gucke glaube
ich der sommer ist vorbei kalendarisch
an ersten sie haben hier bisher
überhaupt nichts abgeliefert
und jetzt können wir zu den dingen die
wirklich wirklich weh tun was wirklich
wirklich wehtut ja das ist dass die
gerade 65 milliarden euro für soziale
umverteilung von ihnen ins feld geführt
werden und wo ist da die
forschungspolitik wo ist der beitrag der
forschungsministerin und des hauses zu
sagen wir sind in einer existentiellen
energiekrise was machen sie denn sie
reden hier gerade von wasserstoff wo es
der wasserstoff in den 65 milliarden ich
habe es überhaupt nicht gefunden
der herr sattelberger ihr ehemaliger
staatssekretär der sattelberger war bei
mark hughes in einem kernforschung
startup und hat gesagt wir müssen da was
machen sie tun aber nichts kernfusion
wer ein super thema um langfristig den
problem was wir heute haben zu begegnen
sie könnten sagen endlich vorbei unserer
ki strategie wir neben 100 professoren
für energie transformation sie haben
aber überhaupt keine idee sie sind die
totale verliererin in diesem programm 65
milliarden 0 für die forschung
und da hilft es auch überhaupt nicht
dass sie das jetzt wett gemacht haben
dass sie die studierenden vergessen
haben damals beim energie geld das jetzt
200 euro bekommen das hilft der
forschung nicht und noch viel schlimmer
noch viel schlimmer sie haben die ganze
zeit erzählt sie würden bei der
forschung nicht kürzen sie haben das in
71 punkten uns auch noch schriftlich
erklärt sie sehen doch was gerade
draußen muss die ganze
forschungsgemeinschaft sagt wir haben
unsicherheit sie haben kürzungen
vorgenommen und sie hat sie nicht
erklärt und sie haben sie auch heute
nicht erklärt sie hätten hier die chance
gehabt dass wir zu erklären sie lassen
die forschungsgemeinschaft einfach im
dunkeln und wenn sie behaupten da ging
es ja nur um mündliche zusagen dann
haben sie überhaupt nicht den prozess
verstanden
das sind forschungsvorhaben die bauen
aufeinander auf wissenschaft zeit
vertrags gesetz das sind alles
drittmittel beschäftigte ein halbes jahr
ist der vorlauf um die leute auf die
nächste phase das projekt zu bringen und
wenn sie jetzt sagen das bisherige
verfahren dass sie eine mündliche zusage
kriegen weil natürlich noch nicht alles
publiziert ist das geld nicht mehr dann
werden sie ganz viele forschen in ein
loch schicken in ein halbes jahr
mindestens loch ist die folge verträge
sind darauf will die
forschungsgemeinschaft auch mal eine
antwort haben sie haben mir heute
überhaupt nichts gesagt nur heiße luft
so
und jetzt können wir wirklich zu den
dingen die noch viel schmerzhafter sind
um das zu steigern das kann man sich
fast gar nicht vorstellen es geht
8,4 millionen kinder waren im schuljahr
2020 und 21 eingeschult
8,4 millionen kinder wann im lockdown
8,4 millionen kinder haben massive
defizite aus gronau egal wie sehr sie
daran glauben ob pur oder noch da ist
oder nicht die defizite sind da die
psychosozialen die lahn rückstände da
haben wir ein programm in der alten
regierung mit den ländern gemacht zwei
milliarden auf wonach bewohner das hat
sicher mängel darauf haben sie
hingewiesen damit wird aber auch einiges
gemacht da wird in klassen eine
honorarkraft dazu genommen damit man
individuell lernen kann da werden
bildungs gutscheine verteilt an kinder
aus den elternhäusern wo eben nicht nur
bibliothek des zur decke steht und neben
dem klavierlehrer auch noch der
nachhilfelehrer kommt sondern genau die
kinder von denen sie mit den chancen
gesprochen haben sie lassen sie jetzt
eiskalt im regen stehen denn sie sagen
einfach ihr kriegt jetzt gar nichts mehr
gar nichts null frauenminister und
stemmen sich dafür und deshalb erwarten
wir dass sie hier endlich mal anfangen
zu arbeiten für dieses land rast um für
die schüler die studierenden und die
forschungen es braucht doch ein
folgeprogramm wenn sie sagen aufholen
nach chur unerreicht nicht dann machen
sie mehr machen sie es anders gehen
sehen die 65 milliarden in die nächste
runde holen sie was für die kinder raus
und auch bei den sprachkurs genau die
gleiche geschichte 6000 sprach kitas
genau in den benachteiligten gebieten wo
sie startchancen schulen bauen wollen es
wird jetzt gestrichen das ist
ländersache genau und genau aus
demselben grund wird auch startchancen
nicht laufen denn statt chancen sie
haben bisher nichts gemacht und wie ich
höre sollen jetzt auch noch die länder
die mehrheit von den ganzen bezahlen von
ministerin nach einem jahr ist das eine
krasse um die worte zu hören eine krasse
bilanz sie sind mit vielen
vorschusslorbeeren gestartet aus der
wissenschaftsgemeinde sie bitte zum
schluss ihrer kollegen jetzt steht die
frage auf dem spiel bauen sie ein
chancen ministerium oder bauen sie das
ministerium der verpassten chancen es
liegt annehmen
nächster redner ist der kollege oliver
kaczmarek für die spd fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
herzog das waren ja wieder schwere worte
und ich hören auch immer zu aber ehrlich
gesagt was jetzt die alternative von
cdu/csu es habe ich immer noch nicht
verstanden wir legen auch keine
alternativen antriebe vor
meine vermutung ist da ist einfach
nichts aber ich werde ihnen auch weiter
zu können vielleicht kommt irgendwann
mal die lösung denn die wahrheit ist
dass wir natürlich auch in diesem
haushalt baustelle übernommen haben die
unerledigt waren ich will ihnen zwei
beispiele gerne nennen meine fraktion
und ich wir waren vor wenigen wochen auf
der polarstern einem prachtstück der
deutschen forschungslandschaft unser
eisbrecher der die aktie fährt und
deswegen haben wir dort haben wir uns
mit der frage auseinandergesetzt was
eigentlich unerledigt geblieben ist und
unerledigt geblieben ist nach jahren ist
die finanzierung des nachfolgeprojekt
die polarstern 2 und das ist unser
verdienst in der koalition gewesen dass
wir es geschafft haben dass die
finanzierung der polarstern zwei
gesichert ist das ist ein ganz wichtiges
signal in die forschungslandschaft
hinein dass der bund auch in schwierigen
zeiten in forschungslandschaft
investieren
zweites beispiel ich will ja gar nicht
verhehlen natürlich war das eine gute
sache dass wir der vergangenen
wahlperiode den zukunftsvertrag studium
und lehre geschaffen haben den
hochschulpakt verstetigt haben die
finanzierung von studienplätzen damit
auch gesichert haben aber es war immer
klar dass wenn der bundesanteil im
zukunftsvertrag nicht auf wächst was sie
ja immer verhindert haben dass es de
facto eine kürzung bei steigenden
personalkosten ist deswegen wie
dynamisieren den zukunftsvertrag studium
und lehre wir bekennen uns zur
verantwortung des bundes für die
finanzierung von studienplätzen auch das
ist ein wichtiges signal in die
wissenschaft zu einfach zu machen
und deshalb nach 16 jahren cdu führung
im bmbf von denen einige bestimmt ganz
gut waren einige aber auch ein bisschen
lustig vielleicht waren würde ich mir da
an der stelle ein bisschen mehr
bescheidenheit wünschen in der kritik an
der jetzt in führung meine damen und
herren
deutschland steht vor riesigen
herausforderungen das ist der rote faden
der haushaltsdebatte die wir jetzt schon
die ganze woche führen und die sorge um
explodierende strom und gaspreise dass
es für viele menschen nicht einfach so
sondern das ist eine existenzielle frage
auch für viele auszubilden und
studierende und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir an der stelle nicht nur darüber
reden sondern dass wir helfen dass wir
handeln und das was wir schon gemacht
haben das ist der heizkostenzuschuss den
wir auch im bafög und in der
berufsausbildungsbeihilfe für
studierende und auszubildende
geöffnet haben und das ist in diesen
wochen die auszahlung der energiepreis
pauschale an alle die studierenden die
einen mini job haben wir wissen das sind
immerhin drei viertel aller studierenden
doch was wir jetzt geschafft haben und
uns gemeinsam in der koalition
vorgenommen haben das ist ein wichtiger
schritt denn wir bekennen uns dazu dass
jetzt alle studierenden eine halbe eine
einmalzahlung in höhe von 100 euro
bekommen sollen dass wir ihnen helfen
die strom und gaspreise ein bisschen
abzufedern ich bin froh dass wir das
gemeinsam in der koalition geschafft
haben
ob frau ministerin jetzt müssen wir noch
gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass der
heizkostenzuschuss 2 der für die
wohngeld empfänger vorgesehen ist auch
wiederum im bafög und der
berufsausbildungsbeihilfe verankert wird
da haben sie uns an ihrer seite wenn wir
das eben auch noch schaffen für studien
und auszubilden
und das ist gegen die richtige botschaft
schwierige lage wir wissen das fängt
nicht alles auf aber wenn die menschen
können sich darauf verlassen wenn wir
sagen wir dass niemand allein auch
auszubilden und studierende nicht und
beim bafög endlich eine kleine
trendwende in sicht aber damit dass
nicht nur eine kleine delle bleibt
sondern sich zu einem richtigen
aufschwung beim barfen bei den
geförderten zahlen führt müssen wir
jetzt kräftig unterstützen und die
bafög-novelle die wir schon beschlossen
haben und die sich jetzt schon im
haushalt befindet die wird einen klaren
beitrag dazu leisten nicht nur weil der
fördersatz auf über 930 euro steigt
sondern weil deutlich höhere freibeträge
die grundlage dafür sind das überhaupt
viel mehr menschen wieder ins bafög
reinkommen können und deswegen ist das
richtig und deswegen will ich auch sagen
auch wenn man nicht die aussicht hat den
höchsten förderbetrag zu kommen
wichtig ist jetzt den bafög antrag zu
stellen allen denjenigen zu sagen die
eine aussicht auf eine förderung haben
stellt den bafög-antrag jede förderung
aus dem bahr verhilft und wir wollen
dass menschen ihren rechtsanspruch aufs
bafög endlich auch durchsetzen können
und dazu hilft die novelle die wir jetzt
auf den weg gebracht haben die schau im
gesetzesblatt steht
meine damen und herren das
ausbildungsjahr hat begonnen und die
lage die bilanz ist gemischt wir haben
immer noch das eine zahl von
abgeschlossenen ausbildungsverträgen die
unter dem kokon nach oder unter dem
niveau von vor corinna liegt wir haben
gleichzeitig eine hohe zahl unbesetzter
stellen und wir haben gleichzeitig eine
hohe zahl ungelernte auf dem
arbeitsmarkt und das ist richtig dass
wir jetzt über wertschätzung für
berufliche bildung sprechen dass werth
berufliche bildung und akademische
bildung tatsächlich und auch materiell
gleichwertig sind das ist ein wichtiges
anliegen dieser koalition aber
wertschätzung für berufliche bildung das
muss doch auch heißen dass jeder die
chance hat überhaupt einen
ausbildungsplatz zu ergattern und zwar
in jeder regierung dieses anders ist
jeder die chance hat damit ein
vernünftiges einkommen zu erzielen
das leder die chance auf einen platz und
ein einkommen zu erzielen und zwar
unabhängig vom schulabschluss nicht nur
jetzt an die abiturientinnen und
abiturienten irgendwie sollen auch in
die berufliche bildung aber die die von
der hauptschule kommen und der zeit vom
ausbildungsmarkt stehen gelassen werden
die müssen wir auch in den blick nehmen
die haben alle eine chance auf
ausbildung verdient und deswegen sage
ich auch von ministerin die
exzellenzinitiative berufliche bildung
ist unser gemeinsames ziel das haben den
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart das wollen
wir und das wird auch kommen aber sie
ist gleichzeitig und untrennbar
verbunden mit der ausbildungsgarantie
die ausbildungsgarantie muss jetzt auch
kommen daran müssen wir gemeinsam in der
koalition in der regierung arbeiten
wie immer bei haushalten ist es so viele
fragen sind noch ungeklärt und kein
haushalt verlässt im bundestag sowie
hereingekommen ist aber die koalition
packt die dinge an die richtung stimmt
bildung forschung bleiben auch in
herausfordernden zeiten priorität für
die bundespolitik erziehen das
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist nicole höchst für
die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
das sind in frau ministerin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren es wird
grundsätzlich die haushaltsdebatte
debatte ergeht sich wieder in orgien der
selbstbeweihräucherung dabei hat die
fortschritts koalition sichtbar den
rückwärtsgang eingelegt rückt selbst die
gew unser land der dichter und denker
erfinder ingenieure unternehmer
nähert sich in wirklichkeit in
riesenschritten einem notstands land an
und was das deutsche bildungssystem so
an blüten hervorbringt sehen wir auch am
weltökonom habeck der sich nicht
entblödet hat bei maischberger in aller
öffentlichkeit sinngemäß zu sagen läden
wie bäcker und blumenläden der nicht
gleich insolvent aber sie hören
vielleicht erst einmal auf zu verkaufen
das sei keine klassische insolvenz hilfe
solche menschen lenken die geschichte
und die geschicke unseres landes und das
meine damen und herren ist ungeheuerlich
und offenbart einmal mehr den
bildungsnotstand
auf der regierungsbank
com ministerin der schwerpunkt ihres
haushalts liegt erkennen beim bereich
wissenschaft und forschung ok
garantieren sie endlich freiheit von
wissenschaft und forschung unterbinden
sie alles was wissenschaft bildung und
forschung zu hören der politik macht die
von digitalen kunden hat unsere
abgeordnete darf ich etwas sagen ich
finde dass das keinen sehr
parlamentarischer wortgebrauch es dehnt
sich ihr benutzten nicht wurde sie sehr
becken wieder dazu zurücktreten
sensoren bundestag die von digitalität
und lockt downs geprägten corona jahre
bei gleichzeitiger massenzuwanderung
haben in allen bildungsbereichen zu
einem beispiellosen niveau fall geführt
die entstandenen lücken können nicht
mehr aufgeholt werden die psychischen
und physischen schäden an unseren
kindern und jugendlichen sind kaum je
wieder gutzumachen das darf sich
keinesfalls wiederholen
der bundesrechnungshof
erteilte den digital packt die note
mangelhaft heißt für sie die digital
packt fast beenden oder dringend
nachzusteuern bedienen sie sich hierzu
gerne an den ideen aus unserem antrag
lehrermangel konsequent bekämpfen ich
bin sehr enttäuscht dass so wenig
expertise aus der teuren und aufwändigen
enquete-kommission
berufliche bildung in der digitalen
arbeitswelt in ihrer arbeit einfließt
kennen sie die ist aus der letzten
legislatur darin findet man vorschläge
und ideen omas um dem zunehmenden
fachkräftemangel zu begegnen
es braucht mehr meister statt master
langfristig sind eine gesellschaft und
ihre sozialsysteme dem untergang geweiht
wenn sie sich im akademischen
elfenbeinturm einschließen wollen sie
dass so eine starke gesellschaft mit
unzähligen netto steuerzahlern hingegen
kann sich ein funktionierendes
bildungssystem mit sozialstaat leisten
theoretiker und sogar einige
orchideenfächer absolventen inklusive
sobald aber parteien sich den staat zur
beute machen und zur eigenen macht
absicherung immer mehr leute staat
abhängig beschäftigen und von der kita
an indoktrinieren stadt bilden kippt
dieses konstrukt wie wir gerade sehen
sie und ihr vorgänger sie tragen die
verantwortung für die verbindung
unheiliger und unheilvoller
abhängigkeiten und den akademisierung
soir und sie von der ampel regierung
funktionieren sichtlich nach dem motto
halt wo sie dumm ich halte
man dabei gehören die weichen in der
bildung so trinkt neu gestellt hin zu
einer zukunft mit humanistischer bildung
auf das kritische kreative freiheitliche
und demokratische streit bei streitbare
geister stetig nachwachsen arbeiten sie
endlich haushalte zum schluss dann
lieben ministerin die ard wird wie schon
all die jahre zuvor konstruktive
vorschläge zum haushalt machen und sie
in allem unterstützen das buch haben sie
wie chips fielen dann
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist es
mir schon noch mal wichtig zu sagen jede
kritik darf hier sehr deutlich
ausgesprochen werden in diesem hause und
wir haben auch schon einiges dazu gehört
aber trotzdem ist die wortwahl eine
wichtige und wir müssen uns nicht
gegenseitig beleidigen wenn wir kritik
üben vielen dank
als nächstes erhält das wort ohne hülle
für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin gestatten
sie mir eine vorbemerkung herr jarzombek
also rein rhetorisch war das wirklich
eine geschliffene rede das muss ich
ihnen wirklich hier so anerkennt
entgegenbringen inhaltlich
inhaltlich haben sie im grunde aber die
regierungsbilanz von 16 jahren unions
geführten bildungsministerium hier
dargestellt und da sage ich ja ja die
haben der ministerin eine ordentliche
eine hohe hypothek hinterlassen wir
geben jetzt alles um das wieder
mitzumachen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
befinden uns in einer von krisen
dominierten zeit und das wirkt sich
natürlich auch auf den haushalt aus aber
für uns als koalition ist ganz klar wir
werden das notwendige finanzieren nicht
nur um auf die krise zu reagieren
sondern gerade um in der krise zu
gestalten um eine neue realität für eine
gute zukunft zu schaffen der einzelplan
30 ist der anteil der
zukunftsinvestitionen und der vorgelegte
entwurf ist eine solide ausgangslage für
die kommen beratungen auch wenn er aus
unserer sicht einige
verbesserungspotenziale offenbart
positiv ist mit der dynamisierung des
zukunftsvertrag es schaffen wir
bundesweit ich planungssicherheit und
verbessern qualität von studium und
lehre nachhaltig als haushälterinnen
haben wir im parlamentarischen verfahren
des letzten jahres dafür gesorgt dass
nun 56 millionen zusätzlich im haushalt
stehen und ich glaube man kann sagen das
ist das richtige signal der stabilität
in einer hochdynamischen zeit
dass wir es mit der chancen und
bildungsgerechtigkeit ernst meinen das
haben wir als koalition schon wenige
monate nach der wahl bewiesen gemeinsam
haben wir eine umfangreiche bafög reform
verabschiedet in den vergangenen jahren
ist die zahl der bafög empfänger innen
massiv zurückgegangen an dieser stelle
herzlichen dank an die union für
maximale studentinnen unfreundlichkeit
bei den bafög regelung aber damit ist
jetzt schluss wir haben versprochen das
bafög zu reformieren und wir halten
dieses versprechen
und
und wir haben bei den entlastungs
paketen auch unsere studios und azubis
immer mitgedacht die ministerin hat es
angesprochen erst das entlastungspaket
230 euro heizkostenzuschuss dazu
steuerliche entlastungen verbesserung
beim mini- und midijobs jetzt entlasten
wir erneut mit einer einmalzahlung von
200 euro heizkostenzuschuss 2 und
natürlich auch das 9 euro ticket sie
sehen wir haben eine menge hinbekommen
in diesen krisenbehafteten zeiten
und was wir auch hinbekommen haben das
ist ein absolutes grünes herzensprojekt
nämlich die polarstern 2 die
vorgängerregierung besser gesagt das cdu
geführte ministerium hat es trotz
hochkonjunktur
trotz sprudelnden steuereinnahmen nicht
geschafft die polarstern zwei
auszufinanzieren wir sicher nun die
finanzierung trotz schuldenbremse und
trotz multipler krisen ich glaube das
sollte ihnen zu denken geben liebe
cdu/csu und und wir leisten so einen
immensen beitrag zur internationalen
klimaforschung der bau kann 2023
beginnen so ermöglichen wir auch in
zukunft bahnbrechende erkenntnisse made
in germany im sinne des klimaschutzes
ein großer erfolg ist das aber ich hab
schon angedeutet es ist nicht alles
rosig und dem einzelplan das will ich
hier auch kritisch anmerken massive
aufwüchse in einigen bereichen gehen zum
teil auf kosten wichtiger
forschungsvorhaben in anderen bereichen
ob klima und nachhaltigkeitsforschung
die geisteswissenschaften oder auch die
gesundheitsforschung all das sind
letztendlich kürzungen von
zukunftsinvestitionen die klimakrise ist
immer stärker zu spüren die demokratie
steht unter druck und die korona folgen
sind nach wie vor verheerend gerade
jetzt müssen wir die richtigen signale
setzen und in diesem forschungsbereichen
investieren denn jeder euro den wir hier
ausgeben kann uns in zukunft millionen
sparen diese voraussicht ist das
fundament nachhaltigen haushaltens und
das müssen wir auch in harten zeiten
leisten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte noch über ein
querschnittsthema sprechen dass meiner
einschätzung nach zu wenig beachtung
findet die förderung beruflicher bildung
ob bei der transformation in eine
klimaneutrale industrienationen im
kontext von arbeit 4.0 oder auch beim
fachkräftemangel die berufliche bildung
ist und bleibt das nadelöhr und deswegen
ist es mehr und uns grünen ein absolutes
anliegen die berufliche bildung weiter
zu stärken wir haben richtig viel zu tun
die gewinnungen und ausbildung von
fachkräften ist eine mammut-aufgabe
zunehmend flexibel erwerbsbiografien
brauchen gut abgestimmte weiterbildungs
und um schulungskonzepte und das ganze
muss natürlich finanziert werden das
bmbf ist hier in der mitverantwortung
und das muss ich jetzt natürlich auch im
haushalt entsprechend man nicht
testieren das ist einer der auftrag für
die kunden beratungen
abschließend möchte ich meine
kritikpunkte noch mal in das richtige
verhältnis setzen
bereinigt um die korona mittel ist es
ein haushalt auf rekordniveau trotz
schuldenbremse trotz einer schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen lage und vielen
unwägbarkeiten sind die investitionen
auf spitzenniveau das lässt sich nicht
wegreden das sind investitionen in die
zukunft in gerechte chancen und
exzellente forschung insgesamt rund 20,6
milliarden dazu kommt ktf mitteln 156
millionen für die weiterentwicklung der
elektromobilität oder auch 295 millionen
für forschung zur grünen wasserstoff
gerade diese art von
zukunftsinvestitionen kann sie von der
union in den letzten jahren leider
vernachlässigt aber aber das passt ganz
gut zu ihrem atom schlingerkurs und dem
total versagen beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren
374 millionen euro sind in diesem
einzelplan gebunden für den rückbau
kerntechnischer
forschungsanlagen
374 millionen da reden wir nur über
forschungsanlagen da reden wir nicht
über den rückbau von kernkraft an wir
merzen ihre altlasten mit diesem
haushalt aus von daher finde ich diese
unqualifizierten angriffe auch absolut
unangebracht in der opposition zu sein
entlässt sie eben nicht aus der
verantwortung und in diesem sinne
wünsche ich uns verantwortungsvolle
haushaltsberatungen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
als nächste rednerin erhält dr petra
sitte für die linken das wort
präsidentin meine damen und herren ich
will drei akut probleme dieses
bundeshaushaltes ansprechen erstens
infolge der preis explosion werden nun
einmalig 200 euro an studierende an
lernende an berufsschulen ausgezahlt
allerdings teilzeit gaststudierende et
cetera werden leer ausgehen
beispielsweise eben auch ukrainische
studierende wer mit fachschülern gemeint
ist bleibt nach jetzigem stand unklar
ohnehin sind die 200 euro machen wir uns
nichts vor ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein
nachdem es schon in der pandemie monate
gedauert hat bis beispielsweise alle
studierende hilfen bekam muss dies nun
mussten diese nun auch bis zum dritten
entlastungspaket warten die 200 euro
müssen genau genommen eigentlich bis zur
nächsten energiekosten rechnungen
aufgespart werden also helfen sie zur
aktuellen preis mit dem im zuge der
aktuellen preissteigerung eigentlich nix
und das ist deshalb so dramatisch weil
jetzt schon ein drittel aller
studierenden in armut lebt und das
allein ist schon unfassbar
hinzu kommt
das sind ja haus immer so nonchalant und
als chancen ministerium bezeichnen ich
frage wo waren sie als es jetzt um mehr
chancen für lernende und für studierende
ging
zweiter eine portion ihrer förderpolitik
zunächst wie lange muss man schon mal
sagen wollen sie sich eigentlich einen
direkten vorgänger regierung messen also
ich finde dieser maßstab muss ihr
eigener koalitionsvertrag seien in
zeiten
in zeiten von krieg klimawandel corona
pandemie und inflation stellen sich halt
an die wissenschaft und forschung
immense herausforderung
wissenschaftspolitik sollte forschung an
friedens orientierte ökologisch
nachhaltigen und sozial gerechten
antworten fördern aber genau diese
ausrichtung ist nicht zu erkennen
und wie oft mussten wir uns heute auch
wieder anhören sie seien eine
fortschritts koalition aber jetzt wird
deutlich dass uns eher rückschritte und
abzüglich der inflation kommt es
faktisch zu einer kürzung bei forschung
und fortschritt und das ist doch gerade
für diese drei parteien inakzeptabel
vor diesem hintergrund das wissen sie so
gut wie ich dir auch die social media
verfolgt kommen massenhaft klagen aus
der wissenschaft community dass projekte
nicht weitergeführt anträge abgelehnt
und keine neuen projekte trotz anderer
ankündigung begonnen werden sie haben
auf unsere anfrage geantwortet dass
keine projekte aus kostengründen
verworfen worden sind also dann frage
ich jetzt mal zurück aus welchen gründen
denn dann antworten soll ihre neue
zukunftsstrategie offensichtlich liefern
aber die kennt ihr niemand die liegt
noch nicht vor sie arbeiten noch daran
ein jahr nach der wahl und schließlich
teilen sie mit dass die ausgaben infolge
des ukraine krieges nicht aufgebracht
werden können war das ist tatsächlich
eine bemerkenswerte feststellung ich
sage ihnen aber wer in kürzester zeit
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr und einen kräftigen
aufstieg für den verteidigungshaushalt
hinbekommt man kann das kritisch sehen
oder auch nicht aber der muss sich
fragen lassen wieso geht das bitte nicht
in bildung und forschung
ein titel des koalitionsvertrags steht
mehr fortschritt wagen fortschritt
beginnt mit jung und forschung das ist
der ausgangspunkt und aktuell verlieren
wir eben wissenschaftliche kompetenz
zahlreiche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler oftmals sowie so prekär
und beschimpften befristet beschäftigt
verlieren ihre anschlussverträge und
müssen ihre forschungen abbrechen das
ist kein schneller impact es ein deep
impact den wir uns überhaupt nicht
leisten können drittens es fällt auf wie
sehr sie technisch technologische
lösungen bevorzugen deshalb gerade der
kollege von den grünen auch noch mal
bestätigt aber forschung zur eindämmung
und prävention beispielsweise von
pandemien zu ihren folgen die post co
wird und zu infektionserkrankungen zu
psychischen erkrankungen insbesondere
bei kinder und jugendlichen bleibt weit
hinter dem notwendigen zurück baden
württemberg das muss man sich mal auf
der zunge zergehen lassen stellt für
posco witt forschung knapp 13 millionen
zur verfügung der bund dagegen nur 10
millionen und angesichts der dramatik
der bevor die betroffenen ist mir das
völlig unverständlich und
unverständlich ist mir auch sie sind
drei parteien ich habe es ja immer
wieder erlebt die jahrelang bildung und
forschung wie eine monstranz vor sich
her getragen haben und wir haben das
auch unterstützt oder ausgerechnet
diesen drei parteien passiert bei der
ersten aufstellung ihres originären
haushaltes eigentlich nichts weiter als
stagnation und deshalb hoffe ich dass
sie die beratungen zu diesem haushalt
nutzen um korrekturen zu setzen
für die fdp fraktion erhält das wort ria
schröder
[Applaus]
es wird ein bisschen widerwillig sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe ich
keine lust darauf erstmals auch 16 jahre
union zurück verweist es müssen aber
insbesondere in den letzten zwei jahren
hatten sie das ja zu verantworten was in
den schulen in deutschland passiert ist
und sie sind auch in fünf langes
ministerien für bildung zuständig und
dass sie sich dann hier hinstellen und
die situation der schulen bereit das
finde ich schon er dreist wir sorgen
dafür dass diesem winter die schule
nicht geschlossen werden
meine damen und herren in dich selten
wird ja bei den fragen der verteilung
von geld metapher eines kuchens bemüht
wer bekommen welches stück vom kuchen
entscheidend ist aber vor allem was drin
steckt im prüf und was sind die zutaten
bildung und forschung sind nicht etwa
die kirsche auf der torte die man
weglassen kann wenn das geld irgendwann
mal nicht reicht sondern sie sind die
hefe im teig sie sorgen dafür dass das
aufstiegsversprechen aufgeht sie sind
das trieb mittel für ein
selbstbestimmtes leben und für eine
faire gesellschaft unser ziel ist es
dass du konditorin oder bäcker des
eigenen lebens sein kannst und deswegen
müssen die backstube fliesen fest sein
mit dem dritten entlastungspaket werden
wir hier für unseren beitrag leisten
denn viele menschen denken gar nicht
mehr an kuchen und weil es schon fürs
brot nicht mehr reicht klar ist nicht
alle folgen des verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg wird auf die ukraine wird
die politik abfedern können aber das
mögliche
das tun wir ich danke der
bildungsministerin dass sie sich für
junge menschen stark gemacht hat alle
studierenden erhalten 200 euro und auch
diejenigen die nicht bafög berechtigt
sind denn die auch die sind mittlerweile
bei knust und knöpfchen angekommen die
sind echt brook und frau sitte die
bekommen ja nicht nur das sondern ihnen
helfen auch die energie pauschale der
heizkostenzuschuss und die
kindergelderhöhung und liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir nebenher noch arbeitet
der hat in diesem winter ab oktober 70
euro mehr wir erhöhen nämlich die
minijob plätze von 450 auf 520 euro und
das ist eine echte entlastung für die
jungen menschen
wir halten im einzelplan 30 die marke
von zwei milliarden euro das ist 20
milliarden euro das ist gut ich will
aber auch gar nicht verhehlen mehr geld
wäre natürlich besser und in einem
haushalt in dem ein großteil der mittel
über viele jahre gebunden ist durch bund
länder vereinbarung oder
völkerrechtliche verträge da werden wir
insgesamt mehr geld benötigen um weitere
leuchtturmprojekte von uns freien
demokraten aber auch von uns als ampel
zu verwirklichen wie das programm
startchancen das uns extrem am herzen
liegt damit wir die vielen ungeförderten
talente in unserem land zum strahlen
bringen ein leuchtturm den können wir
schon jetzt vorweisen und das ist die
immense bahnhöfe form das ist frische
hefe direkt aus dem kühlregal und wir
können jetzt schon sehen wie der teig
aufgeht zum ersten mal seit 2012
erhalten wieder mehr junge menschen ein
bildungsförderung echte aufstiegschance
und das ist eine gute nachricht meine
damen und herren ich
komme zum schluss wäre eine ganze reihe
von großartigen projekten die
dynamisierung des zukunfts vertrags mit
aktionsplan ein schwerpunkt in der
beruflichen aufstiegsfortbildung
innovationsförderung das braucht es für
gute werden sie bitte wirklich zum
schluss mehl zucker butter hefe die
zutaten sind in der schüssel wir packen
jetzt den schneebesen aus dann reden wir
nochmal kräftig um und dann kommt der
ofen in den kuchen vielen dank
[Applaus]
also das wild war jetzt zu schön dass
der ofen mit den kuchen kommt aber das
haben wir glaube ich alle richtig
verstanden es folgt jetzt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion nadine schön
der herd erste präsidentin kollegen zu
legen ist ja nicht das einzige was bei
der koalition zwischen einander geht und
mal schauen was sie so gebacken bekommen
tatsächlich aber wir werden sehen ich
bin jedenfalls sehr besorgt aus der
sommerpause zurück gekehrt ich war über
sommer im gespräch mit vielen forschern
mit verantwortlichen an hochschulen und
ich kann sagen da ist eine riesengroße
verunsicherung
und die verunsicherung hat auch ganz
konkrete gründe und die will ich will
ich gerne nennen in der hoffnung dass
diese koalition aktiv etwas dagegen
unternimmt denn sie sind auch der grund
für die verunsicherung grund nummer eins
das förderkreis thomas jarzombek hat es
bereits angesprochen da waren etliche
professoren
mitarbeitern hochschulen die auf ihre
förderbescheide gewartet haben und das
kommunikationschaos dieses haus ist das
war wirklich enorm das war kein gutes
signal das war verheerend für die ganze
community und das hat für sehr viel
verunsicherung ist
der zweite punkt die kürzung das
zensiert sich an ein schuldner stark
watzinger aber das auswärtige amt und
sie haben die projekte des dld drastisch
gekürzt da geht es zum einen um
studenten die ins ausland gehen so viel
zum thema chancengerechtigkeit das sind
genau die kinder oder die studenten die
unter corona geleitet gelitten haben und
die jetzt nicht ins ausland gehen können
weil die dld kürzungen gekommen sind da
können sie jetzt sagen das bin ich ja
gar nicht schuld das ist frau baerbock
aber das kann ihnen ja nicht
gleichgültig sein und an den hochschulen
fehlen die mittel um die ukrainischen
studenten oder andere auslesen sich die
studenten zu integrieren das ist ein
fatales signal auch in zeiten des
fachkräftemangels und der ukrainischen
flüchtlingsbewegung auch das hat für
massive verunsicherung gesorgt und tut
es immer noch grund sei
die perspektive
werde ähnlich von einem stillstand
quasi und ich habe mich gefragt was war
das für eine seltsame attacke von
ministerin auf die vorgängerregierung
mit der aussage wir hätten da was
zurückgefahren ich will nur noch mal die
zahlen nennen wir haben 25 10 bis 2020
einer haushaltssteigerung und 80 prozent
gehabt und sie haben jetzt von
22 bis 26
ein plus von vier prozent geplant wir
haben eine inflation heute von 7 8
prozent
sie planen den nächsten zwei jahren plus
von 2% und sagen und und sagen wir
hätten gekürzt dabei gab es bei uns eine
steigerung um zehn jahren von 80 prozent
in der ganzen zeit und 150 das ist
wirklich völlig absurd dieser vorwurf
der hier am rednerpult des deutschen
bundestages von einer minister den
erhoben wird ein völlig fassungslos
zum thema
65 milliarden paket ist schon einiges
gesagt worden die wissenschaft die
forschung bleibt geht völlig leer aus
die studenten bekommen wir 200 euro
sacken wissen sie denn auch schon wie
das geld stur zu den studenten kommt bei
christian lindner erklärt hat 100.000
überweisungen pro tag es geht da wäre
ich auch gespannt auf eine antwort aus
ihrem haus denn die studenten brauchen
das geld
und damit komme ich auch schon zum
vierten punkt für die
wirkliche verunsicherung die an den
hochschulen und instituten ist das ist
nämlich die fehlende kommunikation und
auch die planlosigkeit hier ist jeder
der einzelnen zusammenzählen kann weiß
dass sie all das was sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag aufgeschrieben und
versprochen haben nicht halten können
die auf sie haben eine plane mit einem
aufruf von zwei prozent wir haben auf
der anderen seite eine inflation wir
haben steigende energiepreise und wir
haben in
wahnsinniger größenordnung
versprechungen im koalitionsvertrag das
kann nicht zusammen passen sagen sie
entweder wo sie bei den bisherigen
ausgaben kürzen wollen und die neuen
leuchttürme zu finanzieren oder sagen
sie auch welche leuchttürme sie
verzichten wollen damit das was es jetzt
schon gibt auch kontinuierlich
weitergeführt werden kann und alles wird
nicht gehen hier fehlt jegliche
kommunikation hier fehlt jegliche
ehrlichkeit sagen sie den menschen im
land wo sie dran sind dass wir
vernünftige dass wir ehrliche politik
ich verstehe nicht dass man auf der
einen seite und auf unser allen
leuchttürmen sprechen kann und auf der
anderen seiten und diese realitäten
diesen realitäten nicht ins auge schaut
dass es wirklich unehrliche politik
und wenn sie sagen wir sollen vorschläge
machen dann kann ich nur sagen wir
machen vorschläge unserer anträge haben
sie bisher alle abgelehnt und wenn ich
in ihre vorhaben planen schaue dann kann
ich nur sagen die da zu verzichten sie
einfach auf die daten das ist nur stadt
city hat bisher noch kein name überzeugt
stattdessen sind auch hier an den
hochschulen sind jetzt alle verunsichert
weil jeder sich fragt wo kratzen die das
geld zusammen damit ihr lieblingsprojekt
die da die finanziert werden kann und
beim start chancen so klang das ist ja
gut gemeint aber was meinen sie wirklich
dass sie strukturell etwas ändern wenn
sie jede zehnte schule im land
irgendwann in den nächsten jahren wir
haben ja noch nicht mein konzept
unterstützen ich finde sie sollten
lieber dafür sorgen dass das was der
bund ja begonnen und hat nämlich die
länder und die kommunen bei der
nachmittagsbetreuung zu unterstützen
dass das vernünftig aus finanziert wird
ich bin der meinung dass sie eher die
lehrerbildung unterstützen können und
den fachkräftemangel und auch passiert
die digitalisierung der schulen was wir
angefangen haben weiter in sie bitte zum
schluss wir schaffen uns die
chancengerechtigkeit und deshalb meine
bitte beenden sie die verunsicherung an
unseren schulen verzichten sie auf
ideologische projekte und lassen sie
mehr ehrlichkeit einkehren
und es folgt für die spd-fraktion die
kollegin dr vip-gäste
frau präsidentin meine damen herren
werte gäste auf der bühne
diese zeiten sind herausfordernd für
alle das macht die anstehenden
haushaltsberatungen besonders stammen
spannend und wahrscheinlich auch ein
wenig herausforderung aber wäre als
ampelkoalition bereits drei entlastungs
paket vorgelegt von denen alle menschen
in deutschland profitieren weil wir
jetzt in den haushaltsberatungen des
bundesministeriums für bildung und
forschung sind will ich noch ein herr
aufgreifen und auf um auf dich liebe
petra sitte
einzugehen denn wir wollen ja nicht so
stehen lassen als wenn es nur 3 200 euro
energiepreis pauschale gäbe denn es gibt
auch den heizkostenzuschuss für bafög
empfängerinnen wir haben das neuro
ticken so ausgestaltet dass diejenigen
die semesterticket ein schülerticket ein
azubi ticket haben auch jetzt schon von
dem delta von entlastungen profitieren
werden und ich setze auf darauf dass
bitte ich als appell zu verstehen an die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber dass
wir nächste woche die konzentrierte
aktion zusammentritt und wir als
bundesregierung das angebot gemacht
haben bis zu 3000 euro steuerfrei als
informations prämie zu setzen dann
vergessen sie nicht die azubis
unterschätzen sie nicht die wichtigkeit
der zug ist für die nächsten
generationen mit jasmin ibrahimi die
bisher unser
mitstreiterin in der spd fraktion ist
weiß ich dass das vom dgb mit sicherheit
auch gefordert werden wird neben den
direkten entlastungen setzten wir
natürlich weiter auf
energieunabhängigkeit olaf scholz hat
dass der eindruck es gestern dargestellt
wir haben den strompreis bedecke den
verein führen wollen ich bin im übrigen
auch der meinung dass wir noch einen
richtig ausgestalteten gaspreis preis
decke aber wenn wir ehrlich sind an der
stelle wenn sie ehrlich sind an der
stelle dann ist auch damit das ende der
fahnenstange noch nicht erreicht
und wenn wir in bildung und forschung
durch gut durch diesen winter kommen
wollen dann brauchen wir hochschulen
schulen und kitas die stromrechnung auch
bezahlen wollen und dann brauchen wir
günstiges essen in den mensen auch
weiterhin und dann brauchen wir
antworten auf die inflations getriebenen
preissteigerungen in allen bereichen in
der bildung und in der forschung und
weil wir beim bereich bildung angekommen
sind und herzberg auf um sie auf sie
noch einmal einzugehen ich weiß nicht
das hatte man ihrer rede jetzt gar nicht
entnehmen können aber die originäre
zuständigkeit für kitas für schulen und
für hochschulen die liegt bei den
ländern
und dann will ich an dieser stelle als
bildungspolitikerin auch einfach noch
mal fragen welche vorschläge kommen denn
von den ländern welche vorschläge kommen
denn von der cdu wir haben hier noch
keine gehört aber wir haben einen
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der sich
gestern sehr presse deutlich mit einer
drohung er würde im bundesrat nicht
zustimmen geäußert hat und erfordert
noch mehr entlastung ist glaube ist auch
ein bisschen beleidigt weil man ihnen
nicht angerufen hat aber meine frage ist
meine frage ist meine frage ist welche
hausaufgaben haben denn die
landesregierung gemacht welche
hausaufgaben welche vorschläge hat denn
hendrik wüst eingebracht ich will dass
an dieser stelle auch noch mal erinnern
was das oft nicht so präsent ist 52
prozent der steuereinnahmen des staates
gehen an die länder die mehrheit der
steuereinnahmen geht an die länder und
dass sie sich hier hinstellen und alles
mögliche für den originären bereich
fragen ohne mal zu differenzieren das
finde ich schon bisschen und um das
ganze zu nennen das dann komplett
angetreten in nrw dürfen quark
kinderbildungsgesetz keine
rückstellungen machen die haben einen
rücklagen aber es gibt keinerlei
vorschläge der cdu geführten
landesregierung wie die mit diesen
kostensteigerungen umgehen wollen in
meinem wahlkreis wird gerade brot ein
berufskolleg geschlossen zu werden weil
die arme über jedes jahr
500.000 euro zubuttern muss weil die
ersatzschulen so unterfinanziert werden
dass sie nicht auskömmlich finanziert
werden da wird ein berufskolleg
geschlossen wo erzieherinnen und
erzieher so der bereich wo wir den
größten fachkräftemangel haben wo die
ausgebildet werden können vorschläge der
landesregierung zu dem bereich aus dem
schulministerium nicht ersichtlich und
die studierenden werke die auch durch
die länder finanziert werden haben
bereits mitte august die landesregierung
darum gebeten dass sie mehr zuschüsse
brauchen auch hier keine antwort aus dem
wissenschaftsministerium
und ich ziehe das deswegen auf und es
passt leider auch zu den reden die ich
heute von der union geführt haben weil
wir doch in einer situation sind die so
ernst ist das jetzt nicht die zeit ist
mit dem finger zu zeigen auf andere
jeder auch herr wüst wenn er mit einem
finger auf die bundesregierung zeigt 13
finger auf ihn zurück reichsten der
finger des kita ministeriums zwischen
ministerin schon des bildungssystems und
wir sind doch jetzt in der zeit um das
ganz klar zu sagen das ist der haushalt
den wir verhandeln den wir als
bundesregierung und koalition vorgelegt
haben in dem es jetzt darum geht dass
alle da wo sie verantwortung tragen und
da wo wir gestaltungsmöglichkeiten haben
gemeinsam gestalten jeder sollte seiner
verantwortung gerecht werden und
konstruktive oppositionspolitik an
dieser stelle und das erhoffe ich mir
für die nächsten wochen ist es eigene
vorschläge zu machen es ist nicht die
zeit für blockade oder blockade
androhung im bundesrat
meine damen und herren
der haushaltsplanentwurf für 2023 vor
die erst mal sehr gute nachricht für
bildung und forschung ist dass der
plattform wächst in diesen
herausfordernden zeiten und es ist auch
nicht zu vergleichen mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung die wir in
den letzten jahren haben aldi
vergleichen die wir da gerade zugehört
haben finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen zur stelle wir haben uns viel
vorgenommen im koalitionsvertrag auf das
einen unterschied zu vorher wir sind
wesentlich ambitionierter in den
koalitionsverhandlungen macht und meine
these ist auch wir werden trotz der
herausfordernden zeiten am ende mehr
davon umgesetzt haben als es in der
letzten legislatur gehst ist wir
verhandeln parallel zum jetzigen
haushalt das sprint freiheits gesetz wir
wollen die da sie die deutsche agentur
für transfer und innovation gründen an
den start bringen uns ist wichtig dass
wenn es dafür jetzt einen einzelnen
eigenen haushaltstitel gibt die
forschungsförderung für fachhochschulen
darunter befasst aber es wird keine
förderlücke geben wenn die daten nicht
gegründet ist geht das forschungsgeld
trotzdem an die fachhochschulen und wir
haben als haushälterin und haushälter
gab es in einem letzten verfahren schon
sehr gut deutlich gemacht wie wichtig
uns die beiden projekte sind und wir
werden die weiter intensiv begleiten so
wie wir auch in der bereinigungssitzung
mit einem maßgabe beschluss zum ausdruck
gebracht haben im letzten haushaltsjahr
wie wichtig uns das startchancen
programm des und das bleibt uns als spd
fraktion bei teilen wichtig da finden
wir bisher nichts zu im
ministeriumsentwurf und darum werden wir
darüber und über ganz viele andere
haushaltstitel in den nächsten wochen
sprechen ich freue mich darauf und bis
dahin gilt gebrochen so dankbar auf
es folgt für die afg fraktion dr michael
kaufmann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin frau
ministerin geschätzte kolleginnen und
kollegen abgeordnete wir stehen einmal
mehr vor einem haushaltsentwurf der
erkennen lässt dass bildung und
forschung für diese regierung offenbar
in der rubrik kann man mal machen statt
unter top priorität angesiedelt sind die
gesamtausgaben
für forschungsförderung im weitesten
sinn liegen im vorliegenden entwurf
2023 sogar leicht unter dem niveau des
laufenden haushaltsjahres 2022 und das
bei einer inflationsrate optimistisch
gerechnet von rund acht prozent wenn das
reichen soll in deutschland wieder zu
einem der führenden wissenschafts und
innovationsstandort zu machen dann haben
sie wirklich den bezug zur realität
verloren
und sind mit dati und sprint zwei
durchaus ambitionierte projekte ins
leben gerufen worden allein ein blick in
die zahlen ist mehr als ernüchternd
von den gut 300 37 millionen für daten
fließen lediglich knapp 62 millionen in
die konkrete forschungsförderung das ist
im wesentlichen der posten der an
anderer stelle für die forschung an
hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaften haw weggefallen ist und
dann auch noch gekürzt wurde der rest
verteilt sich zum großen teil auf sowohl
klingende begriffe und positionen die
von hitze und kooperationen beratungen
meine damen und herren echte
wertschöpfung entsteht in den laboren
forschungseinrichtungen und nicht in
diskussionsforen und netzwerktreffen
wo bleibt denn die im koalitionsvertrag
versprochene stärkung der hws
mit diesem entwurf werten wie so oft in
dieser regierung die prioritäten auf den
kopf gestellt die dati darf nicht als
strukturförderprogramm enden so lange
eine derartige verengung der förderziele
verfolgt ist der wegfall des hp haushalt
postens forschung an fachhochschulen
natur schild für angewandte
wissenschaften nicht vertretbar frau
ministerin das ist das gegenteil von
planungssicherheit und
natürlich leitet auch dieser haushalt
wieder an technologischer einseitigkeit
stadt alle chancen technologieoffen zu
prüfen werden einseitig über 100
millionen von wasserstoff aus
erneuerbaren energien bereitgestellt
in unseren breiten typisches vorhaben
zugleich ist kein einziger cent für
andere zukunftstechnologien wie die
energetische nutzung der kernenergie
vorgesehen dabei öffnet die kerntechnik
wirtschaftliche chancen für unsere
industrie die kerntechnik ist
genauso wie die wasserstofftechnik eine
eu anerkannt grüner technologie die
unsere energieprobleme nachhaltig lösen
kann trotzdem entscheidet sich
deutschland einmal mehr für einen
rationalen und gefährlichen sonderweg
forschung und wissenschaft brauchen den
freiraum und die mittel neue
zukunftsweisende ideen zu entwickeln und
in die praxis umzusetzen vielen dank
[Applaus]
es folgt die abgeordneten in ashta für
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe frau ministerin der
regierungsentwurf 20 23 ist ein entwurf
in herausfordernden zeiten der russische
angriffskrieg trifft natürlich hart vor
allem das leben der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer und deswegen ist für uns klar
wir werden weiter solidarisch an der
seite der ukraine stehen
aber auch hier auch hier spüren wir die
auswirkungen die uns allen viel
abverlangen und ganz besonders den
menschen die ohnehin wenig geld haben so
treffen die strom- und
gaspreiserhöhungen meine güte vielleicht
gehen sie allemal parlaments ärzten und
lassen sie in die blutdrucksenker
verschreiben oder so sie können ja auch
nicht schlank und die kollegen also
wirklich also die gaspreiserhöhungen
treffen beispielsweise studierenden
besonders hart und deswegen freue ich
mich sehr dass wir alle studierenden und
fachschüler in entlasten mit einer
einmalzahlung von 200 euro und das
zusätzlich zu dem heizkostenzuschuss und
den anderen maßnahmen die sie schon
bekommen haben trotz der äußerst
ausgespannt angespannten haushaltslage
konnten wir im vorliegenden
haushaltsentwurf die historische
bafög-reform solide ausfinanzieren mehr
menschen werden schon ab dem
wintersemester mehr bafög bekommen und
das bringt mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ein weiterer ein weiterer erfolg im
regierungsentwurf für den wir bündnis
können uns stark gemacht haben mit
diesem haushalt beginnt die
dynamisierung des zukunfts vertrags
studium und lehre stärken das heißt
jedes jahr werden jetzt verlässlich drei
prozent mehr geld in die hochschulen
gehen das bedeutet bessere
studienbedingungen bessere lehre und
bessere arbeitsbedingungen in der
forschung meine damen und herren
wir wissen die zukunft des landes hängt
von guter bildung ausbildung und
wissenschaft ab das sichern wir mit
diesen schwerpunkten im haushalt dennoch
möchte ich auch betonen dass wir uns
hier mit einem entwurf erst mal befassen
im laufe des parlamentarischen
verfahrens werden natürlich wir
abgeordnete auch an einigen stellen noch
nachbessern ja die haushaltslage ist
angespannt aber es macht mir schon
wirklich sorge wenn man aus der
wissenschafts community immer mehr zu
hören bekommt vom verloren gegangenen
vertrauen auf grund der
nichtverlängerung ganzer förderlinien
jetzt gilt es dieses vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen
wissenschaft und forschung brauchen
verlässliche rahmenbedingungen und dazu
gehört auch dass man sich auch in
aussicht gestellte bewilligungen
verlassen können muss
ich bin froh das ist bei der förderlinie
mächtig zum extremismus forschung
gelungen ist zumindest das schlimmste zu
verhindern denn gerade jetzt für unsere
demokratie wieder von extrem rechts
massiv bedroht wird wäre es ein fataler
fehler in diesem bereich zu kürzen
gerade jetzt in zeiten der pandemie und
der hybriden bedrohung durch russland
greifen des informationskampagnen und
gruppenbezogene menschlichkeit immer
mehr um sich und genau hier kann die
wissenschaft einen essentiellen beitrag
leisten und deshalb müssen wir sie hier
auch endlich gut aus finanzieren
und es ist kein geheimnis auch bei der
klimaforschung haben wir natürlich noch
gesprächsbedarf es ist gut dass wir das
forschungsschiff polarstern 2 auf den
weg gebracht haben das wird einen
wichtigen beitrag zur klimaforschung
leisten
aber auch fördermaßnahmen wie bio tipp
die sich unter anderem mit den folgen
der klimakrise beschäftigen sind auch
nötiger als je zuvor die klimakrise ist
eine existenzielle bedrohung
wissenschaft und forschung können hier
einfach leisten und auch das müssen wir
entsprechend aus finanzieren
grundsätzlich müssen wir auch den
bildungsbereich noch mal genau ansehen
in vielen branchen haben wir ein fatales
fachkräfteproblem und gestern fand der
fachkräfte gipfel der bundesregierung
statt habe ich bin froh dass die
ministerin die große relevanz der
beruflichen bildung sieht und das macht
mich zuversichtlich dass wir es auch
schaffen werden in diesem haushalt das
noch entsprechend abzusichern meine
kollegin anja reinalter mit der gleich
noch mehr zu sagen meine damen und
herren
jeder cent den wir heute in bildung
stecken zahlt sich mehrfach aus jeder
cent den wir heute an bildung in
forschung sparen wird uns später
deutlich mehr kosten deswegen ist für
uns klar wir dürfen uns nicht weiter in
diese krise hineinsparen
deswegen sollten wir auch ehrlich meiner
meinung nach noch mal offen über
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten sprechen und
ja das bedeutet meiner persönlichen
meinung nach auch dass wir uns in
münchen unter umständen die
schuldenbremse noch mal anschauen müssen
auch das ist für mich eine frage der
generationengerechtigkeit
in diesem sinne ich freue mich sehr auf
das parlamentarische verfahren
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es folgt daniela ludwig für die cdu csu
fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir sollten uns die schuldenbremse
vielleicht noch mal anschauen ich wollte
euch starten mit dem startchancen
programm wenn sie sich die
schuldenbremse noch mal anschauen wollen
ist es genau das gegenteil von staat und
chancen für die zukünftigen generationen
meine liebe kollegin was sollten sie
vielleicht noch mal dringend dringend
darüber nachdenken wo wir sehr bei ihnen
sind ist die frage wie priorisieren wir
knappe mittel richtig und ich habe dir
ich habe das stichwort schon genannt ich
habe es auch heute aus ihren reihen
öfter schon geführt
startchancen programm wir bisher nur die
begrifflichkeit gehört das zog sich auch
schon durch die letzte haushaltsdebatte
wir warten machen vor sehnsüchtig auf
inhalte zu diesem programm denn wir
würden es durchaus für richtig finden
wenn der bund sich auch weiter in der
verantwortung sieht an brennpunkt
standorten etwas zu tun jetzt müssen sie
mir dabei helfen jetzt habe ich aus
ihren reden entnommen der
bildungsföderalismus ist so wichtig und
sie sind dafür eigentlich gar nicht
zuständig machen sie jetzt die
startchancen programm genau aus diesem
grunde dann doch nicht oder gilt es nur
für dinge die elf jahre lang wie die
sprach kitas aus den alten regierungen
super funktioniert haben die dürfen sie
mit dieser begründung ein stand von dass
es bitte die länder machen sollen also
diese fehlende logik sollten sie mir an
der stelle vielleicht schon nochmal mir
ist es auch nicht mehr
selbstverständlich sie wollen den staat
chancen programm machen mit
brennpunktschulen sie stampfen gesprach
kitas ein mit der liebevollen begründung
sollen doch die länder allein machen sie
zerstören funktionierende strukturen sie
nehmen billigen auf dem rücken der
kinder in kauf dass zum 31 12 perfekt
ausgebildete fachkräfte auf der straße
stehen ohne die chance einer
weiterbeschäftigung und sie nehmen
billigend in kauf dass die von
entstandenen lücken durch corona und da
können uns jetzt trefflich streiten ob
die schulschließungen richtig waren oder
nicht ich wollte immer kritikerinnen
davon gar kein thema das hilft mir aber
jetzt nix ich wir müssen den kindern
helfen bei denen lücken entstanden sind
wir haben ein programm aufgelegt 2
milliarden euro aufholen noch corona
auch da kann man trefflich darüber
streiten dass der ein oder andere euro
vielleicht nicht da angekommen ist wo
sollte man hätte natürlich in zeiten wo
entscheidungen brenzlig waren schwierig
schnell getroffen werden mussten
vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken können
auch meine erste bildungsstand erhebung
wem hilft das vor ort ich denke dass es
richtig war er zu gehen und zu sagen wir
machen etwas wir machen es auch mit den
ländern wohl wissen dass sie vielleicht
auch nicht alleine könnten aber ich
halte es für richtig dass wir uns als
bund ja auch in die verantwortung nehmen
lassen und darum liebe frau ministerin
akzeptiere ich auch nicht ins laufen fuß
zu sagen er das mit den sprach geht das
liegt dabei der andere ministerin für
familie ich glaube für kinder sind wir
alle zuständig und wenn es um die
bildung der kinder geht dann hätte ich
von der bildungsministerin
zumindest mal ein veto erwartet als es
darum ging die sprach kitas zu beenden
denn was des vor ort jetzt auslöst was
das vor ort jetzt auslöst ist fatal wir
haben als union heute lieber kollege tom
beck einen kita gipfel dazu gemacht es
waren über 500 leute nadine schön
zugeschaltet und die kitas dies betrifft
und das sind in jedem wahlkreis sehr
sehr viele sehr viele und zwar nicht nur
in den städtischen bereichen sondern
auch im ländlichen raum die sind
wirklich verzweifelt die sind
verzweifelt und zwar nicht weil sie an
zwischen land und nicht nur weil es um
die zukunft der einzelnen fachkräfte
geht sondern weil es um die kinder geht
es genau darum geht dass wir die lücken
die wir jetzt nicht schließen später
sehr sehr teuer bezahlen werden und das
ist es was ich ihnen ehrlicherweise echt
nicht durchgehen lassen kann es ist so
ein großer fehler den sie sich da
erlauben und den werden sie sicherlich
noch sehr sehr lange spüren das
verspreche ich ihnen und wir werden sie
da auch nicht aus der verpflichtung
lassen lassen sie uns gemeinsam rottweil
diesem gott bei diesem förderprogramm
lassen sie uns gemeinsam darüber reden
wir übers verstetigen können wir bieten
ihnen hier die zusammenarbeit an es ist
wichtig für unsere kinder wir müssen uns
verstetigen diesen sich nicht zurück auf
diese total simple niveaulose
argumentation soll es halt die länder
alleine machen wir wollen und sie wollen
doch auch chancengleichheit wenn wir die
chancengleichheit herstellen wollen dann
brauchen wir gerade für die sprachliche
bildung flächendeckend überall die
gleichen rahmenbedingungen lassen sie es
mit uns gemeinsam machen wir stehen zur
verfügung und sind die kinder definitiv
wert vielen dank
für eine kurzintervention erteile ich
das wort gier jensen
vielen dank frau präsidentin dass sie
die intervention zu lassen frau kollegin
ludwig wir haben gestern ja auch in dem
entsprechenden einzelplan über die
sprache kitas debattiert ich möchte
einerseits weil sie gesagt haben dass
bildung uns alle angeht und dem möchte
ich ausdrücklich zustimmen sie fragen ob
sie auch dann als fachpolitikerin und
fach politik als haushälterin und
haushälter mal in die mittelfristige
finanzplanung auch der letzten jahre
geschaut haben weil sie sicher sehr
darüber überrascht zeigen dass die
sprach kitas wie sie es formulieren
auslaufen da ist kein geld mehr
eingestellt worden weil geplant
planmäßig geplant war dass diese sprach
kita programme auslaufen was ihr bei
gestern auch im haushalts in der debatte
gehört haben ist dass der
bundesfinanzminister gemeinsam mit der
familienministerin vereinbart hat das in
den nächsten zwei jahren jeweils zwei
milliarden euro zur verfügung stehen
besonders in qualität investiert wird
unter anderem kammern unter qualität
extrem diese sprachförderung fassen und
wir setzen uns gemeinsam mit dem
ministerium mit in der koalition dafür
ein dass genau aus diesen mitteln auch
ein übergang finanziert wird um die
länder strukturen bis sie aufgebaut
werden zu finanzieren und ich finde das
können sie doch dann mit uns
unterstützen und wir freuen uns an
dieser stelle auf die konstruktive
zusammenarbeit denn was sie hier gestern
in der einzelplan debatte zu dem
haushalt aus dem familienministerium
gemacht haben das war nicht konstruktiv
sondern das war schüren von angst auf
dem auf dem rücken der kinder und auf
dem rücken der fachkräfte die das
betrifft und das finde ich nicht
konstruktiv und deswegen werden wir
ihnen diese zusammenarbeit
selbstverständlich anbieten und uns auf
die debatte in den nächsten wochen
freuen
v abgeordnete ludwig sie dürfen
antworten
frau präsidentin vielen dank die zwei
milliarden die sie ansprechen frau
kollegin haben mit den sprachkurs nichts
zu tun und das wissen sie auch dass es
die fortschreibung des gute kita
gesetzes es geht uns jetzt dezidiert um
ein gut laufendes über jahre immer
wieder evaluiert des bundesprogramm das
ganz spezifisch sich auf die sprachliche
bildung konzentriert und wo wir jetzt
zehn nach corona die großen lücken
ausgerechnet jetzt hier zu gehen und zu
sagen jetzt lassen wir es aus laufen und
wir sagen euch das drei monate vorher
viel spaß bei der umsetzung so geht es
nicht und das ist auch von innen nicht
konstruktiv unterlassen sie die leute
vor ort die sich um die kinder kümmern
im regen stehen ich habe angeboten wir
haben angeboten lassen sie uns
spezifisch über die sprach kitas reden
immer wieder laut und nicht automatisch
recht aber das wissen sie am besten
lassen sie uns gerne miteinander über
die sprache kitas reden aber vermengen
wir bitte nicht gute kita gesetz das
angekündigte kita qualitäts gesetz das
hat damit 0,8 nichts zu tun uns geht es
darum dass sie jetzt riskieren dass zum
31 12 unwiederbringlich
funktionierende permanent evaluierte
strukturen kaputt gehen und die zielen
sie nicht mehr auf die schnelle am
zweiten januar wieder hoch und das ist
unsere befürchtung und das möchten wir
verhindern
[Musik]
das wort erhält der abgeordnete dr
stefan seite für die fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe mein manuskript das ich mir
vorbereitet habt jetzt einfach zur seite
gelegt warum auch ich war im sommer
unterwegs und habe knapp 20 hochschulen
besucht ich komme ja bis sie wissen aus
der community und die unsicherheit ist
wirklich groß die unsicherheit ist aber
deswegen groß weil niemand so richtig
weiß wir sind unserer volkswirtschaft
weiter geht wie es mit den
steuereinnahmen ausgeht und wie
letztendlich das dann auswirkungen hat
auf nicht nur 2023 sondern auf 24 25 26
und viele stimmen haben wir da gesagt
wenn ihr das diskutiert in berlin dann
diskutiert das bitte ohne polemik ohne
parteipolitischen interessen sondern und
kümmert euch darum dass
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden wie
denen wir in der zukunft ordentlich
arbeiten können und es wurde auch gesagt
das verständnis da ist das förderlinien
auslaufen werden klar ist es dass man
enttäuscht ist wenn das die linie auf
die man gehofft hat nicht wieder
stattfindet aber das verständnis ist
dafür auch da und ich denke da können
wir auch wieder vertrauen aufbauen und
arbeiten da muss ich auch eines sagen
wenn du heute kritisiert wird das ist
jetzt im übergang von dieser von der
letzten zu dieser regierung
schwierigkeiten gab dann muss ich ihnen
sagen diese erfahrung habe ich selbst
dann gemacht wenn die gleiche partei
dauerhaft an der regierung war dass es
unterbrechungen gab das ist eine
erfahrung aus dem leben was bedeutet das
dass mit knappen mitteln es bedeutet
dass wir letztendlich
priorisieren müssen und diese
priorisierung hat stattgefunden
und ich finde es interessant dass
einerseits die priorisierung gefördert
wird wenn sie dann stattfindet wird sie
tatsächlich wieder kritisiert klar weil
vielleicht projekte dabei sind die man
selbst als nicht diejenigen betrachtet
die man gerne gehabt aber wir haben
projekte auf den weg gegeben die
einerseits im klimabereich wirkungen
zeiten werden
vorstand 2 wir haben die dinge auf den
weg gegeben wie zb beförderung wir haben
in diesem land ein riesiges problem dass
die nachfrage nach den studien gegen
zurückgehen da müssen uns nun kümmern
und kümmert sich auch direkt diese ampel
koalition und wir haben auch
strategische ausrichtungen vor und da
muss ich in ein tagen lieber denkt ein
ministerium vielleicht eine runde länger
nach als dann dinge zu beschließen in
einem schnellschuss die einen die bürger
kurz mal einen dreistelligen höheren
millionenbetrag wasser und die sind
komme ich zum schluss man möchte einfach
sagen ich freue mich auf die vorschläge
aus der opposition es gibt viele dinge
die wir diskutieren können thema
berufliche bildung andere dinge aber
lassen sie uns das
zielorientiert diskutieren und ohne
polemik vielen dank
als nächsten redner das wort markus buhl
für die afg faktor
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die geplanten mittel für das
bildungs und forschungsministerium
liegen auch für 2023 bei etwa 20
milliarden euro der haushalt ist ein
gemischtwarenladen mit sinnvollen
hochtechnologie projekten wie dem
teilchenbeschleuniger in darmstadt
hinter denen wir natürlich stehen aber
leider auch mit jeder menge links grüner
ideologie bei der wir streichen wäre und
auch für 2023 priorisieren die privat
organisierte agenturen wie zb die da
diese wurde schon mehrfach genannt bei
der wir die deutliche gefahr von
doppelstrukturen zu lasten der
steuerzahler sehen einen weiteren fehler
begehen sie bei der viel zu kurz
gefassten förderungen der beruflichen
bildung die sinkenden ausbildungszahlen
im handwerk und in der industrie sind
eine katastrophe für unsere wirtschaft
sie sind das resultat einer
jahrzehntelang über akademisierung
unsere duale ausbildung ist ein
erfolgsmodell das weltweit einen guten
ruf genießt frau ministerin es ist
höchste zeit dass die berufliche bildung
wieder umfassend wertgeschätzt und
intensiv gefördert wird anstatt sich wie
seit vielen jahren einseitig auf
akademische laufbahn zu konzentrieren
um bildung zu vermitteln brauchen wir
genügend lehrer um moderne schulgebäude
und da sieht es genauso katastrophal aus
die vielen unterrichtsausfälle sind
nichts anderes als ein skandal die
verantwortlichen in den ländern hatten
genug zeit für mehr ausgebildetes
personal und sanierte schulen zu sorgen
stattdessen sehen wir einen schlecht
umgesetzten digital packt schüler bei
dem der bundesrechnungshof über
mangelnde bedarfsprüfung oder viel zu
bürokratische prozesse und abläufe
berichtet die marode substanz unserer
schulen ist mittlerweile ein massives
problem was nützt das neueste tablet
wenn keine lehrer da sind um zu
unterrichten die sanitären du nicht
funktionieren der putz von den wänden
fällt oder fenster nicht zu öffnen sind
der immens hohe investitionsrückstand
wird mittlerweile auf über 46 milliarden
euro beziffert und belegt die anhaltende
vernachlässigung von schulinfrastruktur
durch die bundesländer
wir wollen einen zukunftspakt schule
schaffen der kommunen bei
schulsanierungen hilft die sanierung
unserer schulen ist dringend notwendig
ein konjunkturimpuls und eine
zukunftsinvestition
frau ministerin der bund kann nicht
tatenlos zusehen es ist zeit zu handeln
werden wir haben daher um die stücke
unterstützung für unseren antrag vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist für die
spd-fraktion meyer wolfstein
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen guten abend
ihnen auf der tribüne und vielen dank
dass sie so lange aushalten und das auch
noch beim thema wie bundeshaushalt und
das in so einer schwierigen situation
wir haben ja eine haushalt der
wahnsinnig unter druck ist das ist allen
klar und da heißt es mehr denn je
prioritäten setzen und das ist ein
heißes eisen probieren sie es mal
aussprechen sie mal in familien oder
freundeskreis mit dieser frage und
fragen sie mal was wäre aus seiner sicht
das wichtigste politische feld in der
aktuellen lage und da sagt natürlich die
eine gesundheit der andere solidarität
mit schwächeren die wirtschaftliche
stabilität deutschlands bildung und
natürlich auch frieden und so etwas
stelle ich mir das im übrigen auch im
kabinett vor und das problem ist alle
haben natürlich recht
und natürlich müssen wir das irgendwie
alles zusammen hinkriegen die gute
nachricht ist ich habe da eine lösung
aber das verrate ich am ende
rhede ihnen liebe frau ministerin stark
watzinger ist es trotz der zwänge
gelungen das für bildung und forschung
nächstes jahre und 200 millionen mehr
ausgegeben werden sollen als dieses und
dafür möchte ich in meinen respekt
aussprechen vielen dank
wir müssen aber auch das klare
bekenntnis zu unseren hochschulen im
koalitionsvertrag mit den richtigen
zahlen auch im haushalt unterlegen es
sind die hochschulen die gerade mit
großem engagement
studierende aus der ukraine willkommen
heißen es sind die hochschulen die seit
fünf semester corona pandemie sehr darum
kämpfen dass ihre studierenden
trotzdem die bestmöglichen
studienbedingungen haben und die
hochschulen in brandenburg oder auch
anderswo haben jetzt bereits pläne für
den winter erstellt wie die präsenz wäre
auch bei gasknappheit weiter gehen kann
kann der klimakrise transformation krieg
für all diese herausforderung kann
forschung antworten liefern und mit
blick auf die pöbeln den herrschaften
hier rechts im haus die sich ja einen
dramatischen winter wünschen wir wissen
möchte ich den fokus schärfen für die
bedeutung der lenz vor spritze jens
forschung es geht um die
widerstandsfähigkeit unserer
gesellschaft gegen flache parolen es
geht um den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt der gerade in der krise
besonders wichtig ist wir müssen der
krise auf allen ebenen herberg sie
wollen auch der krise überhaupt nicht
her werden sie brauchen die krise und
das macht mich wütend das macht mich
wütend wirklich viele menschen in meinem
wahlkreis in der lausitz wundervolle
menschen haben nach bestem wissen und
gewissen merkwürdigerweise ein kreuz bei
ihnen gemacht aus in der annahme dass
die sich für die einsetzen werden aus
sehnsucht nach normalität nach frieden
und ruhe aber sie stehen für das
gegenteil sie brauchen vorlieben auch
verzweiflung das ist doch das
lebenselexier afd und das geht mir
mittlerweile schon offen zu
sie freuen sich auf einen heißen herbst
folgen auf unseren straßen austragen sie
missbrauchen ihre wählerinnen und
wählern sie nehmen uns alle insbesondere
uns oft deutsche in geiselhaft und das
mache ich ihn auch zum vorwurf es geht
ihnen nicht um ein normales deutschland
was normales passt nämlich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht in die welt der a steht
denn normal ist jede einzelne
vielfältige facette in unser aller leben
und wissen sie was wissen sie was
schreien hat bei mir überhaupt keine
funktion denn ich bin fußball
schiedsrichterin einer schreit ändere
ich nicht meine meinung
wir brauchen forschung zu
gesellschaftlicher gesehen zusammenhalt
demokratie und frieden wir brauchen eine
verlässliche
verlässliche förderung der geistes und
sozialwissenschaften ich nehme hier das
ministerium beim wort so jetzt die
lösung ich bin nicht glücklich mit der
einnahmeseite auf der dieser
haushaltsentwurf basiert aber hier ein
versprechen wenn sie liebe frau
ministerin bei ihrem parteikollegen beim
finanzminister christian lindner
vorstellig werden um erfolgreich für
eine stärkere einnahmeseite zum beispiel
schuldenbremse vermögenssteuer
erbschaftssteuer gibt viele ideen zu
werben dann liebe frau ministerin
bewerbe ich mich als um den posten als
erste vorsitzende ihres fanclubs vielen
dank
für die cdu csu fraktion hält jetzt das
wort kerstin radomski
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
geehrte frau ministerin
ich stelle fest hier sind viele menschen
versammelt die sich wirklich ernsthaft
um das thema bildung und forschung herr
jarzombek bemühen
und uns allen tut offensichtlich diese
uhrzeit nicht besonders gut
[Applaus]
ich habe noch nie und ich bin dem ekin
deligöz wirklich die älteste
haushaltspolitikerin diesen diesen
einzelplan betreut ich habe noch nie so
eine debatte erlebt die langjährigsten
entschuldigung
ich möchte jetzt etwas ruhe in die
debatte zum schluss reinbringen
zum 1 muss ich jetzt aber am anfang
sagen auch wenn einige vorredner
versucht haben die bewährungsfrist der
neuen bundesregierung noch auszudehnen
nein sie ist jetzt vorbei das ist der
zweite haushalt den sie vorwiegend frau
ministerin und natürlich schauen wir auf
den haushalt wir schauen auf ihren
entwurf und wir schauen auch was anders
gemacht werden kann im gegensatz zu
manchem vorredner sehe ich aber schon
dass wir diesen haushalt in schwierigen
zeiten diskutieren das sei das sei
einmal gesagt und vielleicht denen die
emotionen dann an dieser stelle auch so
hoch genau aus diesem grund weil
oppositionsfraktionen gerne unterstellt
wird schon das kritisieren wegen das
haar in der suppe zu suchen fange ich
jetzt mal anders an und heben konsens
hervor ich glaube wir sind uns alle
einig dass derzeit viel zu tun ist um
diese herausforderung zu meistern
und vor dem hintergrund des krieges in
der ukraine und der verknappung
energieträgern wir brauchen viel und
gerade auch in der umwelttechnologie und
wenn wir dann beim installieren von
solaranlagen oder von h zum wärmepumpen
schauen dann stellen wir alle gemeinsam
eins fest uns fehlen die fachkräfte
so und dann bin ich auch wieder
opposition an der stelle frau ministerin
uns fehlen kraft fachkräfte uns fehlen
die auszubildenden es fehlt an vielem in
deutschland aber dann kann man natürlich
nicht etwas tun man kann nicht gerade in
dem bereich berufliche bildung streichen
obwohl auch als haushälter weil ich geld
ist nicht alles man kann natürlich auch
neue strukturen schaffen man kann dinge
anders angehen aber dass wir vor diesen
herausforderungen stehen dass uns die
fachkräfte fehlen und dass uns die
auszubildenden fehlen für die zukunft um
all das zu erreichen was vielen von uns
hier wichtig ist das ist glaube ich
inzwischen jedem klar
und dann hab ich jetzt eine
ampelkoalition vor mir die heute mal
nicht miteinander gestritten hat sondern
fiel auf der vergangenheit auch bin
laden hat ich möchte aber doch zu ihrem
einzelplan zurück kommen und fragen mich
ob da immer so einigkeit zwischen ihnen
besteht also ich würde jetzt zum
beispiel die grünen fragen und sie haben
ja noch die chance darauf zu antworten
was meinen sie dazu dass die mittel für
die strategien zur durchsetzung von
chancengerechtigkeit für frauen in
bildung und forschung gekürzt werden ich
kann auch die spd fragen was sagen sie
dazu dass für die sozial und
geisteswissenschaftliche forschung rund
zehn millionen euro weniger angesetzt
sind und ist es vielleicht im sinne der
grünen schon zum wiederholten male bei 1
titeln der gruppe nachhaltigkeit klima
energie zu kürzen nein liebe ampel es
reicht nicht dass man ein
forschungsschiff auf den weg gebracht
hat nein geld in einen haushalt
einzustellen ist nicht auf den weg
gebracht da gehört eine ausschreibung
dazu da gehört ganz viel mehr dazu als
einfach nur geld in ein schaufenster zu
stellen ich freue mich wenn wir
irgendwann dieses neue forschungsschiff
haben aber noch haben sie leider nichts
auf den weg gebracht und dann denke ich
jetzt mal an ihren ampel
koalitionsvertrag wie wenig davon in den
letzten monaten umgesetzt worden ist
haben wir schon gehört da ist ein
gesetzesvorhaben das jetzt immer gelobt
wird bafög ich würde von einem
reförmchen sprechen aber das ist das was
umgesetzt wurde in dem minister in dem
ministerium bildung und forschung sitzen
1400 mitarbeiter bitte geben sie als
ampel und auf frau ministerin geben sie
denen eine chance zu arbeiten und dinge
voranzubringen im haushalt seien hoch
fehlt das schon viel erwähnte
startchancen programm dabei steht es im
koalitionsvertrag
und wurde in eine maßgabe beschluss der
ampel koalition schon für den haushalt
20 23 gefordert und auch das noch
ausstehende schlüssige daten konzept
fehlt und jahr fester ich weiß was
konstruktive oppositionspolitik ist in
den letzten beratungen habe ich
angemahnt dass wir eine sperre auf die
tat umsetzen und ich bin froh dass wir
das alle gemeinsam gemacht haben das ist
konstruktive oppositionspolitik aber wir
sollten vielleicht hier vor den großen
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
nicht darauf verfallen über länder
politik zu reden denn das hier ist der
deutsche bundestag und alles andere
können wir dann in den landtag
besprechen
meine damen und herren angesichts des
sichtlichen handlungsbedarf freue ich
mich auf die vor uns liegenden
haushaltsberatung ich möchte das
konstruktiv mit ihnen angehen ich glaube
wir können gemeinsam viel erreichen an
der stelle wir werden uns natürlich
weiterhin auch kritisch zug bestimmten
positionen äußern aber ich wünsche uns
allen einen schönen abend und gute
beratung dankeschön
fielen dann kommt als nächste rednerin
erhält das wort doktor an jahr ein alte
für bündnis 90 die grünen
bt frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrte frau
ministerin ja wir reden über den
einzelplan 30 und darum reden wir
natürlich auch über berufliche bildung
und ich habe aufmerksam zugehört und bin
ihnen dankbar frau kollegin radomski
dass sie jetzt das thema fachkräfte und
berufliche bildung auch angesprochen
haben denn berufliche bildung ist der
hebel im kampf gegen den
fachkräftemangel und bis 2030 werden uns
durch den fachkräftemangel sage und
schreibe
4,2 milliarden arbeitsstunden fehlen das
sind 4,2 milliarden arbeitsstunden in
den keine wärmepumpen gebaut werden
installiert worden denn keine häuser
gedämmt worden denn keine elektrische
gebaut haben das sind 4,2 milliarden
arbeitsstunden die uns im kampf gegen
die klimakrise fehlen und diesen kampf
können wir nicht verlieren
und darum investiert die ampel in diesem
haus zahle die berufliche bildung und in
die qualifizierung von arbeitskräften
denn ohne fachkräfte wird uns das klima
um die ohren fliegen das ist fakt darum
haben wir die außen weiterbildung
attraktiver und wir haben die seit
jahren überfällige reform für grafik auf
den weg gebracht und 850 millionen in
dem haushalt bereitgestellt das sind 66
millionen mehr als im letzten jahr davon
profitieren studierende und natürlich
schülerinnen und schüler und azubis und
wir investieren in eine moderne und
digitale berufliche bildung mit 20
millionen euro für das projekt im bett
und mit 29 millionen euro für den
innovationswettbewerb inhalt starten wir
und das ist zentral die gleichwertigkeit
von beruflicher und akademischer bildung
sehr geehrte frau ministerin ich freue
mich wirklich sehr auf die
exzellenzinitiative für berufliche
bildung das wird bestimmt ein sehr sehr
gutes leuchtturmprojekt wir sind
gespannt leuchtturm es sind wichtig sie
sind von weitem sichtbar und sie geben
orientierung
es braucht aber nicht nur leuchttürme
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass alle
betriebe und alle azubis festen boden
unter den füßen bekommen und deswegen
werden wir genau hinschauen ob dieser
haushalt der beruflichen bildung gerecht
wird
was besten boden bringt das sind
maßnahmen wie die initiative
bildungsketten und natürlich der
flächendeckende ausbau von jugend berufs
agentur denn damit unterstützen wir
schülerinnen und schüler ihre ganz
persönlichen bildungsweg zu finden und
wir helfen betrieben die passende azubis
die passenden azubis einzustellen und
außerdem senken wir dadurch die
vertragslösung hotel das versteht ja
eigentlich auch jeder denn was ist
frustrierender als eine abgebrochene
ausbildung und zwar für beide seiten für
die azubis und für die betriebe oder
studium klar aber das gehört alles zu
beruflichen bildung und darum werden wir
der beruflichen bildung in dieser
parlamentarischen beratung den
rückenwind geben
lassen sie jetzt bei der suche nach
fachkräften aber auch unseren eigenen
tellerrand hinausschauen in meinem
wahlkreis biberach war das immer wieder
gefragt warum die vielen qualifizierten
menschen aus syrien und der ukraine bei
uns eigentlich nicht arbeiten dürfen wir
haben was die antwort unser
einwanderungsgesetz ist immer noch viel
zu exklusiv und die anerkennung von
abschlüssen ist teuer und bürokratisch
und stadt hier im haushalt zu kürzen
müssen wir gerade jetzt die finanzierung
von unterstützungsangeboten sichern
also
mit diesem haushalt können wir die
richtigen weichen stellen den
fachkräftemangel einzupacken und ich
freue mich und bedanke mich für ihr
angebot konstruktive beratungen im
ausschuss bzw konsumiert und
konstruktive beratungen vielen dank und
ebenfalls ein schönes
punktlandung genau was die zeit betrifft
und jetzt folgt holger mann für die spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren die
haushaltsentwurf des bmbf wächst im
kommenden jahr um ein prozent auf und
das haben wir jetzt in der debatte schon
gemerkt ja das ist angesichts der
aktuellen kostensteigerungen nicht viel
aber eben angesichts der
rahmenbedingungen die wir haben alles
andere als selbstverständlich und
immerhin mehr als im vergangenen jahr
als ort es kommt also es kommt also auf
die politische prioritätensetzung nicht
zuletzt im einzelplan selbst und mehr
vielleicht als bisher noch auf das
parlaments verfahren also uns alle
positiv hervorheben möchte ich aber
vorher die bereits erfolgte strukturelle
änderungen beim zukunftsvertrag wie von
uns gemeinsam in der ampel in den
koalitionsvertrag verankert steht im
haushaltsentwurf nun die dynamisierung
des zukunftsvertrag die hochschulen und
die akademien erhalten zukünftig wie die
forschungsgemeinschaft und verlässliche
aufwüchse jährlich drei prozent mehr
dieses jahr macht dies konkret 57
millionen aus und frauchen nein ich
glaube nicht dass wir die hochschulen
verunsichern wir bieten hier spielräume
und mehr stabilität und die
voraussetzungen dafür dass die
beschäftigten an den hochschulen
wahrnehmbaren lohnsteigerungen erwarten
war sei dann der stelle aber auch mal
gesagt nun stehen eben auch die länder
in der pflicht ihren teile dafür bei zu
wollen im innovationsbereich sind für
neue förderstrukturen wie die noch im
aufbau befindlichen agenturen sprint und
da die wirklich große aufwüchse
vorgesehen auch das sei zu loben und
hervorzuheben dass es im übrigen auch
kleinere summen sein können mit denen
man veränderungen anstoßen kann zeigt er
mit nun fünf millionen waren die titel
für soziale innovation wie ich finde
sind das hoffnungsvolle neuanfängen
und
kein auch sei gesagt gleichzeitig gibt
es deutliche verschiebungen zwischen den
forschungsfeldern der haushaltsentwurf
sieht ja das kann man positiv sehen hohe
ansätze bei forschungen zur
digitalisierung und technologien vor
diese steigerung stehen aber eben auch
deutliche kürzungen in anderen
programmen linien nämlich den der human
und geisteswissenschaften sowie der
medizin gegenüber und ob diese
priorisierung die richtige reaktion auf
multiple krisen pandemie krieg
fachkräftemangel oder klimawandel ist
das meine ich müssen wir in den
haushaltsberatungen schon noch mal
miteinander diskutieren aber das gehört
zur ehrlichkeit angesichts knapper
mittel sollten wir dann stärker auch
gemeinsam hinterfragen ob erneut
zuwächse in anderen titeln von über 50%
sachgerecht sind und wird die überhaupt
immer sinnvoll ausgeben können denn
andere positionen fallen derzeit noch
hinter die erstausgaben des jahres 221
zurück werden teilweise aktiv gekürzt
und da ein beispiel ich auch prominent
nennen weil es mir besonders aufgefallen
ist die bildungs worden die
bildungsforschung wird im zweiten jahr
in folge in mehreren kapiteln und titeln
um zweistellige anteile gekürzt so die
empirische bildungsforschung die
forschung zur wissenschafts und
hochschuleinrichtungen selber oder zur
digitalen hochschulbildung und das sage
ich ganz deutlich das halte ich im
moment für einen falschen ansatz zum
einen weil damit die grundlage für
erfolgskontrolle und rationale
entscheidungen untergraben wird an denen
wir alle gemeinsam hier interesse haben
sollen zum zweiten weil die forschung
eine wichtige voraussetzung ist für die
kooperation mit den bundesländern die
wir zumindest in der ampel deutlich
ausbauen wollen und zum dritten weil die
vermittlung aller disziplinen nicht
zuletzt auf deren erkenntnissen fußt
meine damen und herren deswegen bin ich
der meinung dass wir uns diese kürzung
in diesem maße in diesem bereich
wahrsten sinne des wortes nicht leisten
ein weiterer aspekt dieser kürzung muss
ich auch problematisieren er kam mir
schon zur sprache genau diese kürzung
bei der bildungsforschung trifft eben
schon wieder die geistes und
sozialwissenschaften frau
bundesministerin stark watzinger ich
weiß dass ihr haus bemüht es den
eindruck kommunikativ entgegenzutreten
der haushalt ist aber bekanntlich in
zahlen gegossene politik und deswegen
hoffe ich dass wir an dieser stelle noch
eine veränderung erreichen ein anderes
beispiel wäre im moment die ddr
forschung gehe noch nicht weiß ob es in
den kommenden zwei jahren mit einer
weitere finanzierung rechnen kann ich
glaube zu sagen wir stehen eben nicht
nur promotionen transfer und strukturen
auf dem spiel sondern schicksale und
deswegen habe ich die bitte und hoffnung
dass wir hier gemeinsam in sachgerechten
schwierigen concessions hätte nie so
wichtigen änderungen
und den abschluss dieser debatte macht
kathrin schau für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte ministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich möchte auch voranstellen dass der
einzelplan 30 vor dem hintergrund der
aktuellen krise insgesamt stabil bleibt
und das ein positives signal ist
gemessen an der zuständigkeit der länder
für die schulische bildung und vor dem
hintergrund dass auch die länder derzeit
unterstützungsmaßnahmen auf den weg
bringen muss der bund aber natürlich
seien verlässlichen anteil an den
insgesamten ausgaben sicherstellen es
ist gut dass der bund die hochschule mit
der qualitätsoffensive lehrerbildung
unterstützt mit dem programm leistung
macht schule und schule macht stark
fördert der bund ebenfalls gemeinsam mit
den ländern sowohl leistungsstarke
kinder und jugendliche als auch sozial
benachteiligte schülerinnen wichtig und
unverzichtbar ist die förderung der mint
bildung entlang der bildungskette mit
dem wind aktionsplan 2.0
gleiches muss auch verstärkt für die
angebote der kulturellen bildung der
bildung für nachhaltige entwicklung und
der volkshochschulen gelten im
vorliegenden regierungsentwurf kommt es
durch umschichtung in einzelnen titeln
neben videos wie dem titel stärken der
leistungsfähigkeit des bildungswesens zu
deutlichen mittel absenkung über die wir
in den kommenden haushaltsberatungen
bringen sprechen müssen
auch wir möchten der beruflichen bildung
noch den nötigen rückenwind geben denn
hier gehören alle in den blick und und
dafür auch die notwendige finanzierung
ich zitiere aus der delphi befragen und
der dkjs und der bertelsmann-stiftung
jugendliche mit niedriger schulbildung
haben erheblich eingeschränkte
ausbildungs perspektiven dabei werden
aus sicht der experten die
qualitätsanforderungen in den
ausbildungsberufen die für jugendliche
mit niedrigen schulabschlüssen relevant
sind steigen im sommer 2020 verließen in
deutschland bundesweit knapp
169.000 schülerinnen und schüler die
schule ohne schulabschluss
beziehungsweise mit einem hauptschule
bzw
vor abschluss dies entspricht einem
anteil von 22 5 prozent aller
schulabgängerin trotz vieler unbesetzte
ausbildungsstellen bleibt mehr als ein
drittel der jungen leute mit
hauptschulabschluss zwischen 20 und 34
jahren ohne ausbildung von denjenigen
ohne schulabschluss sind es sogar fast
zwei drittel
dieser bildungs verlauf kündigt sich
früh an immer mehr grundschulkindern
fehlen gemessen an den von der
kultusministerkonferenz festgelegten
standards grundlegende fähigkeiten in
den fächern mathe und deutsch jeder
fünfte viertklässler startet am lesen zu
hören und in mathematik eine
rechtschreibung fast jeder dritte
während der korona pandemie vieles noch
stärker ins gewicht und das wissen wir
dass es bundesweit vielerorts an
lehrkräften geeigneten räumen an
digitale ausstattung und an weiteren
pädagogischen kraft fachkräften mangelt
so waren und sind kinder benachteiligt
die probleme haben die im unterricht zu
folgen und damit ganz verlernt pakete
unordentlich gepackt mit sich
herumtragen eltern können das nicht
auffangen und lehrkräfte gelangen
permanent an ihre belastungsgrenzen ca
20 prozent der kinder in deutschland
wachsenden armut auf ihre oft in
prekären verhältnissen lebenden eltern
haben sich vielfach damit abgefunden
daran nichts ändern zu können und diese
negativ dieses negative zukunftsbild
macht etwas mit den kindern wenn
psychische oder suchterkrankungen der
eltern hinzu kommen und wenn kinder
gewalt erleben sind die negativen
auswirkungen auf das lernverhalten und
vermögen sowie auf die soziale kompetenz
der oft auf sich allein gestellten
kinder um ein vielfaches höher als bei
den kindern die in soliden und
gesicherten verhältnissen aufwachsen mit
dem start chancen programm haben die im
ohr vertrag den zusammenhang von bildung
und sozialer herkunft adressiert es ist
notwendig aber nicht trivial ein
programm von so grosser reichweite auf
den weg zu bringen das grundlegend
wirken soll die erfahrungen bisheriger
bund länder programme insbesondere auch
von erfolgreichen länder initiativen
müssen hier mit einfließen die
voraussetzungen der einzelnen
länderspielen für die erfolgreiche
umsetzung eines große rolle ebenso die
wissenschaftliche begleitung mit dem
digital packt schule gemeinsam kraftakt
von bund und ländern mit ihren
kommunalen und privaten schulträgern ob
proben wir eine neue und notwendige form
in der bildungszusammenarbeit die
motivation er selbst auf der einsicht in
die notwendigkeit erhebliche
investitionen in die digitalisierung des
bildungswesen und wir meinen die chancen
für 20 prozent für mindestens 20 prozent
der kinder in unserem land sollte
motivation genug sein ich danke ihnen
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
einzelplan liegen wir nicht vor wir sind
damit am schluss unserer heutigen
tagesordnung ich berufe die nächste
sitzung des deutschen bundestages ein
auf morgen freitag den 9 september
2022 um 9 uhr die sitzung ist geschossen